is peter barton i'm the associate
director of the institute thanks for
joining us for this richard m carp
distinguished lecture
we established this series to celebrate
the role of the founding director of the
institute dick carp in theoretical
computer science
the series features visionary leaders
in tcs and neighbouring areas and it's
geared towards a broad scientific
audience and we're grateful to the many
contributors to the richard m carp fund
who have made the series possible i'm
delighted to welcome our speaker today
caroline uhler
caroline's the henry l and grace doherty
associate professor at mit and ecs and
idss
and she's the co-director of the eric
and wendy schmidt
center at the broad institute of mit and
harvard
as well as degrees from the university
of zurich and
i'm sorry from the university of zurich
caroline has a phd in statistics from uc
berkeley she came here on a fulbright
award
and she was also a research fellow in
the very first semester
that we had at the simons institute in
the program on theoretical foundations
of big data analysis
caroline's made important contributions
in machine learning statistics and
computational biology in particular in
causal inference in generative modelling
and in applications of these to genomics
she's been awarded the sloan fellowship
and the nsf career award and she's a
simon's investigator
and this semester she's one of the
organizers of the semester program on
causality
and and earlier she
was a visitor for berkeley for that
program um so we're very pleased to have
caroline speaking today on causality and
auto encoders in light of drug
repurposing for covert 19.
welcome caroline
thank you so much peter
and i'm really excited to be speaking
here in this um richard carp lecture um
i still very fondly remember you know in
my first year during my phd and when i
took
his course in fact
on algorithms and molecular biology and
he really showed me how you know you can
really very nicely marry your love for
foundational developments in computer
science with really going after
important questions in biology and um
that's
what you know i'm trying to do um also
for my own research and my group's
research and so
that kind of also already gets me
started in terms of where i want to go
today so i will start off by and then i
started thinking for this course about
you know for this lecture um about you
know if if i were to just choose one
particular problem in machine learning
um that you know really needs um
theoretical developments in what would
it be in order to impact the most have
the most impact on on biomedical kinds
of questions
and what i want to propose that to be is
is
something that you know we'll hear
term um causal
representation learning
and i want to discuss why causal
representation learning what could
causal representation learning even mean
and what are different kinds of
approaches to get a causal
representation learning but really i'm
mainly going to ask questions in this
talk and not provide too many answers
and trying to connect that to research
that is going on in causality right now
and and trying to show different kinds
of opportunities um for you know where
theory theoretical developments and
causality could really help to answer um
and to lead to new approaches in the
biomedical sciences
okay so first why what why is there a
need for something that i'll hear coin
causal representation learning and then
talk a little bit more about
about what i mean by it um so first of
all why representation learning so
that's easier to answer
so the biomedical sciences as we all
know has seen this huge you know
explosion in different data sets and we
have and these are at different scales
right we have all kinds of genetic
information at the dna level then we can
measure
expression of at a single cell level of
all of our genes so all of our 20 000
genes and we can get to imaging of
tissues or even you know imaging and of
course medical imaging of whole body
parts
um and all of these different data
modalities have to be integrated in
order to get a full picture
now you know often in biology we don't
know what we're going after right so we
don't we cannot just label these data
sets because we don't know what we're
going after so we have huge amounts of
unlabeled data
and we know you know of these amazing um
amazing success stories that
representation learning has had in
different areas of like say for example
um integrating um captions and and
images say so for text and images
um so we're in a similar position here
that we have all these very different
data modalities and of course we want to
find some integrated representations in
order to learn the most about
what we're actually seeing about the
underlying biomedical problems
now why causality and why are just the
standard representation learning tools
that have been developed in machine
learning for other types of questions
why might they not be sufficient
um
so i think in the biomedical sciences
you actually often just not just care
about prediction but really about more
than just predictions so let's think
about you know your standard machine
learning applications that motivate a
whole lot of development that have
motivated a whole lot of developments in
machine learning say like recommender
systems right in a recommender system i
don't really care
why
you know if i'm interested in buying
sunscreen i might also be interested in
buying ice cream right but you know you
just only care about that you that these
recommender systems have a high
prediction accuracy i really don't care
about you know the underlying
understanding the underlying question of
why that that is maybe because the
weather is good right now and that's why
you know i might be interested in both
of these
but if we're thinking about biomedical
questions and you know here is a very
well-known melanoma data set which you
might be familiar with where
you know you have like a whole
collection of of uh benign and malignant
skin lesions and you know you may want
to understand better what makes it
benign and what makes it a malignant
skin lesion now in this particular data
set um the benign class is actually over
represented for these um bandages or
different types of bandages and it turns
out that the malignant class and that's
what we showed here is actually
over-represented for these measuring
bars so you can imagine right if you
just train your standard neural network
on these types of of these types of
problems well it will be using whatever
you give it and in particular it will
make use of these kinds of features um
and will therefore do very poorly in
downstream tasks if you're applying this
in a different kind of say hospital
setting
and it's doing poorly because it's not
using causal features right it's not you
know these features here are not causal
and therefore will not be transportable
to a different kind of to a different
kind of environment so you really care
about you know not just for
understanding the underlying biology and
understanding the underlying you know
medical question of like what makes this
a different um that's of course one
motivation but also just for for being
able to to really apply these um these
kinds of tools in in real biomedical
settings
um
so that leads me to you know thinking
about that we need something that
combines the two right where we kind of
can find representations that are not
just predictive but actually causal
and i think what is really so exciting
and i'll talk about different ideas and
i'll just be presenting mainly three
ideas in this talk of for causal
representation learning but i think what
is so exciting in biology and the
biomedical sciences is that there is
this huge hammer that we can use in
order to get at something like this
so i think unlike and you know there are
some fields that are now
getting there as well but like unlike
most other fields um what you have in
the biomedical sciences for getting at
causality is this huge hammer that you
can actually perform large-scale
perturbations
so we can for example knock out any gene
we like so meaning just set the
expression of these genes to zero right
using crispr technologies for example
and see what happens if you do that so
you can intervene or perturb or in the
causal language intervene in the system
in such a way um and in in basically
many different ways right of knocking
out say different kinds of genes and
actually seeing what happens to the
system
or you can apply a drug that's also an
intervention or perturbation in the
system and see what happens downstream
and of course interventions are really
useful in order to get at causality
right think at this particular picture
here where you know say we want to
establish whether whether good weather
um causes you to eat more ice cream or
the other way around
well if you can intervene on the system
and say you go to a city and you just
give out free ice cream you'll see that
the weather doesn't change and then can
establish that you know the ice cream is
definitely downstream from from good
weather right so these interventions can
really help you in order to establish
something about causal directions
and should be really helpful if we're
thinking about getting at causal
representations
so that's the motivation at a high level
from a computational perspective let me
give you also very particular or a
particular view on you know that can
kind of
unify many of the problems that people
are really working on nowadays in single
cell biology and try to put them into a
unified framework and then try to see
why causal representation learning might
actually be what we need in order to
make progress on these different types
of
questions in single cell biology
um so here are site four types of
questions in single cell biology um that
you know many of the problems that
people are studying now can be put into
um and let me go through these and you
see here that you know i have two
different levels so this will tell you
already something about causality so
we'll have here just the observational
level and here we have actually the
level where you do have interventional
data or perturbational data so let me
just start up here and tell you just
some questions at the observational data
and this is related to what i said at
the beginning that you know in the
biomedical sciences we now often have
very different data modalities available
to us um so here and i'm talking here
just about the single cell lab single
cell data sets but you can you the same
questions arise also if you're thinking
about um the tissue level or also the
organism level
um so for example you know data sets
that are very widely available are
single cell imaging data sets so here
you see each one of these pictures is a
picture of a single cell and you can
also get single cell sequencing data
sets so here for example every row here
is one cell and you get to measure the
expression of all of our 20 000 genes
now what you would really like to be
able to do and this is at the cell level
and also at the at the tissue level is
you would really love to be able to
translate between them right i give you
an image like this could you predict
what the expression profile is
and the other way around but maybe more
interested you're really of going from
images to expression just because images
are much much cheaper to obtain and also
less less work intensive so something
like this is something that you would
really love to be able to do um and so
there is a lot of you know questions
about inter integrating different data
modalities but also translating between
different data modalities
um so this is a question
at the data
observational setting i get observations
of single cells where i take some for
imaging and some for sequencing and let
me try to be able to integrate or um or
translate between them and very similar
or questions about moving between
different time points i don't want to
spend too much time on here but you know
these are also questions about you know
i have some some snapshots of data sets
say you're in cancer progression at
different time points and
these these different um you know these
processes are often so long that you
cannot just watch these cells as they go
throughout time so you would like to be
able to move forward and backward in
time which is very similar to the
question here of different data
modalities
so that's at the observational level and
you see like all these questions just
putting them in a very unifying
framework of just as transport problems
in single cell biology um what about
when we also have interventional data
okay so when you have interventional
data then here i have two different
types of questions that you know
basically um i think encompass like most
of the questions that people would be
excited or interested in trying to solve
this one here is the first one that i
have here is also known in the causal
literature as causal transportability so
what is this problem and it's basically
at the at the forefront of everything
that people want to do in in the
pharmacological industry is say you have
like different interventions um that you
have tested on
say in in mouse okay
um so here are all my drugs and i have
performed these drug screens and mouse
well what you would really love to be
able to do is this causal
transportability problem of i know what
the effect is of these drugs and mice
well can i predict the effect of these
drugs in humans right so um let's think
of this in the policy setting right
that's where this problem has mainly
been studied i have like a particular
policy that i have introduced in a
particular city well can i then predict
the effect of this particular policy in
a different city by understanding the
differences between these different
cities so this problem is known as
causal transportability i try to predict
the effect of an intervention that i
have seen in one context try to
transport that to a different context
and predict its effect
um so this is of course an extreme case
of trying to go from mice to humans but
the problem and i'll get back to this
you know a bit less extreme is i have
performed this large drug screen or also
genetic screen whatever you want to do
different types of interventions on
different kinds of cancer cell lines
okay so these are actually available
data sets and now here comes a new
disease like source cough ii um covet
19. now you have a new cell line namely
source cough two infected lung
epithelial cells and you know you would
prefer not to have to redo this whole
huge screen right on all of these
different thousands and ten thousands
and hundred thousands of different drugs
and and inter interventions that you
have tested in the cancer setting but
you would love to be able to do to
predict you know what will these drugs
actually do on source cuff to infected
lung epithelial cells if you can predict
that well then you may be able to rank
your drugs right based on which drug we
call this drug signature what is the
drug signature and which drug signature
may be most anti-correlated with a
disease signature because this might be
a good drug um that may be able to move
you back from the disease state back to
the normal state
okay so these questions you know you can
also move them to the less extreme
setting of like trying to go from one
disease context to actually a different
disease context
here is a different um causal transport
question um which is to move between
different interventions so here again i
have you know here many different types
of interventions say i have knockouts
and you know humans have 20 000 genes
nowadays you can do screens where you
knock out one gene after the other so
for all these 20 000 genes you can
actually do that but you know you'll
never be able to do all combinations of
knockouts right i mean even if i look at
20 000 choose 5 and then i want to do 20
000 choose 3 etc i'll never be able to
do any you know all of these experiments
so at some point you need to be able to
predict the effect of new interventions
or new combinations of interventions or
if you're thinking about the drug
context right i have done a drug screen
on some molecules well i have new
molecules and i would like to be able to
predict what will happen if i actually
um if i apply this particular new
molecule to my cells
so this is a it's another causal
transport question
which is transporting between different
types of interventions okay so here i'm
transporting between different contexts
say i have some perturbations i've seen
them in one cell type or one one disease
context i'd like to be able to predict
what happens in a different disease
context and here i have seen some
perturbations some interventions that
like to predict the effect of new
interventions
um so this is you know encompasses a lot
of as you see here right a lot of
important questions say um in the
pharmacological setting or here you know
in the basic biological setting of
really trying to really understand how
different data modalities um are related
to each other
and um
what i want to do now is of course here
it kind of already seems clear that
something like causal representation
learning will be critical right we care
about causality because we care about
predicting the effect of an intervention
which only has an effect downstream of
it and some type of representation
learning will be critical because we
have all these different kinds of data
modalities that we need to integrate
um so but now let me first maybe take a
step back and ask you know how would
these questions you know more
traditionally be be looked at okay
and you know traditionally if you try to
predict the effect of of a knockout say
or for over a particular intervention
then how biologists have always pictured
this and what the ultimate goal was was
in biology is to really get at
completely the underlying mechanistic
model of how you know what is actually
happening in a cell so how are genes
interacting with each other which gene
turns up or down which other gene and
really learn these you know very large
scale um these very large-scale genetic
networks here where the nodes are genes
right and the edges tell you which gene
and how it regulates which other gene
and
you know thinking about these networks
so also thinking about how that relates
to causality the sewell right was um you
know institut was a geneticist but
really developed the foundations of much
of the field of causality today uh where
he has he comes from studying heredity
um in genetics and and you know drew out
these kinds of networks which
are causal networks um and tell you um
you know about heredity information in
in these species
and this is in some sense how we're
looking at these um these gene
regulatory networks themselves as well
and let me just give you you know what
is that the kind of framework that's
will write developed at the time um
these are these causal structural
equation models it's a very very
intuitive model of how you know these
networks here can be read where you know
if we're thinking about it in the gene
in the gene regulatory space my nodes
here these are random variables these
are genes
um they're random you know there's some
randomness because this is the
expression this measures the expression
of a particular gene um and it's a very
intuitive model where you know a node
here so you have this directed graph
that corresponds to causal relationships
and a node here is some function of its
parents and noise okay so here for
example x4 is a function of x2 and x3
and some noise these functions of course
can be highly non-linear which is the
case also often in in genomics right and
the noise of course doesn't have to be
gaussian doesn't have to be additive etc
so you know if we're thinking about our
problems here on the previous six um in
the previous setting where you know if
you try to predict the effect of a
knockout well if you have the full
understanding of this underlying you
know regulatory network well then you
can actually predict the effect of a
knockout right and so you know into like
what what we then would want to do and
what i was excited about you know many
years back when i saw how large scale
how large these observational um single
cell gene expression data data sets
became is to ask well maybe we can
use you know some this kind of framework
and try to from observational data on
the nodes try to actually infer these
networks right and then we could solve
some of the questions that i asked on
the previous slide in terms of
predicting what happens if i'm setting
one of these genes to zero
so let's talk a little bit about
structure discovery and causal structure
discovery um and you know this is a rich
history and and is a very still very
active field today and i'll give of
course some more references afterwards
but you know here um it's really started
like by very foundational work by peter
spurtus of um telling us of course you
know we know as i already said at the
beginning right if you just have
correlations like good you know good
weather and ice cream and just from
observational data itself we cannot tell
which direction it's going but you can
learn some of the underlying um
directions even just from observational
data and you know peter spurt has um you
know proved results about what can be
identified and also provided algorithms
for actually learning these causal
graphs just from data itself on the
nodes
so you know if we try now to think of
like well then you know that's exciting
right can we just apply this and learn
these gene regulatory networks from um
from data on the nodes
um that led us down to really asking
about you know how how good do these
algorithms perform and what are their
assumptions needed in order to provide
the correct graph um when you have just
observational data on the notes
and what is really interesting is you
know a fun fundamental assumption behind
these algorithms for for causal
structure discovery something known as
faithfulness
um which says the following that
you know here if we're just looking at
three genes um and you know gene one
could have a positive effect on gene two
so up regulate gene two but gene one you
know could also have a negative effect
on say this gene three and then gene
three upregulates gene two
so of course it could happen and these
things do happen in biology that you
know different kinds of paths the effect
along different paths can cancel each
other out now the faithfulness
assumption what it assumes is that this
doesn't happen okay that paths along
different paths do not cancel each other
out because it's a problem when when you
have that happen and you're trying to
learn the structure because now because
they cancel each other out in the data
it looks like gene one and gene two are
independent of each other and so if
they're independent then you would
remove some edges between them like this
one here right and that would lead to a
wrong graph
so that's a faithfulness assumption that
says that these paths counts that they
are not allowed to cancel each other out
now of course if you have infinite
amount of data then the probability of
this happening right that this exactly
cancels each other out well that that
has you know has measures zero so you
can say like well maybe i don't care
about these types of assumptions but
think about when you actually have you
know sample sizes that are not infinite
right how do we actually do independence
testing well we have some threshold
where we're saying like well you know
i'm going to decide that these two genes
are independent if their correlation is
small enough
but as soon as you're entering like
you're adding a threshold then of course
this this assumption doesn't have
measure zero anymore and so that's what
we had quantified you know an earlier
work and shown that you know this
assumption is actually a very strong
assumption when when you have finite
sample sizes and you know it will be so
strong that even like if you have like
10 node graphs and you know you have
quite large sample sizes like even a
million samples then even for very
sparse graphs this assumption basically
doesn't i mean with probability one
doesn't hold meaning that in all these
in these kinds of cases you will for for
the algorithms that assume faithfulness
and you know and i will get to like
questions about is this like do you
really need this assumption or not but
something like this is what is needed
and we still don't know whether in fact
the really minimal assumptions needed
but something like faithfulness is
needed so this this just means that with
the you know then these algorithms will
not get the graph right so you need huge
amounts of data in causality for just
learning the underlying causal graph so
for performing structural uh structure
learning
in causality from just observational
data
so that's a problem of course and and
you know that was when i moved to mit in
fact and and when i got introduced at
the broad um to the kinds of uh the data
sets that would be coming out soon and
what got me really really excited so i
was very discouraged when i was working
on you know single cell rna-seq data
sets and trying to learn these gene
regulatory networks
now you know what was being developed at
the time is like these large-scale
perturbational screens right that you
can actually now go in and intervene on
any gene you like um and this should
give you more information you know as we
said before right if you go out and
provide everyone ice cream and you see
that nothing changes upstream that well
that the weather doesn't change then you
know that you know the weather is
certainly not downstream of of your
perturbation right so perturbational
data should give you a whole lot of of
more information and so this then
motivates the question of asking you
know from a theoretical perspective well
how how much more can you learn when you
also have interventional data um
together with observational data might
that may become a you know get you
closer to the kinds of two algorithms
that you could actually use in this uh
genomic setting in order to learn these
gene regulatory networks
and there is a lot of literature here um
in this
for causal structure discovery from
interventional data um and um you know
here i'm just
stating some of it that we've you know
we were very excited about it early on
um working building on on frederick
aberhard's formalism that he had
developed of like how to even think
about interventional data sets and then
developing algorithms like these over
here um that can really combine
observational and interventional data in
order to learn these these causal graphs
now you know there's under i always want
to highlight people that are actually at
assignments um long-term participants
here there's a lot of people working in
this area like sarah malia connie and
daniel malinsky currently there um and
you know and and you know these these
algorithms they do work of course better
than just when you have only
observational data but here i'm just
showing some results to show you that
we're still far away from doing anything
that would really get us to gene
regulatory networks i mean here i'm
showing just graphs on 24 nodes we have
huge numbers of samples and you know
these uh false positive true positive
kinds of curves here are not something
that we're happy with um in order to
really learn these gene regulatory
networks and i'm very excited about more
theoretical computer science work that
people have started nowadays um with
rnob and kostis who are at the simons
institute who are really thinking more
more deeply about you know how much more
information does actually interventional
data can interventional data provide you
as compared to observational data really
getting a theoretical framework for
thinking about these kinds of trade-offs
and also sample complexity results of
how much data you really need um in
order to just estimate the parameters in
these causal graphs or really learn
these graphs as well
okay so that's kind of where we are i
think in terms of you know i'm trying to
learn these gene regulatory networks
from a mix of observational and
interventional data
and so that brings me back to this kind
of question right so here you know yes
one approaches and this is the standard
approach is to try to really learn this
underlying gene regulatory network and
then try to answer these types of
questions what will happen if i knock
out a particular gene
but you know there is a question of
whether this is really necessary right
is it really i mean if i if these are
the questions that i in the end want to
answer do i really have to go this full
route of actually learning the
underlying gene regulatory network
and so that's um what i want to be
talking about now and um maybe give you
some ideas of like maybe maybe you know
we can get around it without actually
going this whole path
okay
now um
you know i'm talking about causal
representation learning and um what what
you need or what we want to do here is
of course we need to somehow be able to
generate data corresponding to a new
intervention right so i have some
interventions that i've seen here and
all of these questions they're all
generative kinds of questions i need i
want to be able to predict what happens
when i'm performing a particular
intervention in a new context or here
you know what happens for a new type of
intervention that i have not yet seen so
as you see everywhere here i'm trying to
generate data corresponding to that
intervention corresponding to a new
modality corresponding to a new time
point
um so definitely what i'll need is some
type of generative model and what i will
be using here are auto encoders just
because um we understand them um
quite well i think or the types of
things that we need to understand we
have or starting to understand at least
um so you know we all know about the
amazing success stories of of neural
networks and how they've you know being
used in the standard discriminative
modeling setting what i'm going to talk
about here and what we need right for
these types of questions are to really
apply them in the generative model
settings so where we want to generate
new data sets a new data point
corresponding say to a new intervention
now alt encoders are you know a form of
non-linear principle component analysis
where you're using a neural network in
order to embed from your data set say
images or or sequencing data to some
lower dimensional latent space and then
you have another neural network that
maps you back to the original data
modality and these are trained by just
minimizing the reconstruction error here
okay so these are you know quite simple
in the sense but um so always used for
dimension reduction now what you'll see
in this talk and might sound a little
bit crazy at first is that i'm going to
use auto encoders in a non-standard way
in fact i've never used them this way
namely we're not using auto encoders for
dimension reduction but i'm going to use
auto encoders for embedding the data
into a higher dimensional latent space
than what you started off with
okay so this may sound crazy and might
sound like something why would you ever
want to do something like this because
now you have enough parameters in order
to just learn the identity map here
um
and
yes that's the case okay but and so
maybe that means that i'm not learning
any interesting um any interesting thing
in this latent space but you know i
think we we
have work here where we're actually
characterizing what are the functions
learned when you're going through these
you know larger dimensional latent
spaces and you know there is a lot of
motivation for why to look at larger
wider and wider neural networks because
they have seen at least in the in the
standard classification setting to
perform actually very very well okay so
that motivates for us or has had
motivated us at that point to actually
look at alter encoders where we're going
to a larger dimensional latent space and
i'll tell you a bit about afterwards
like how this might relate to causality
okay but just already here to provide so
what i mean by an over parameterized
auto encoder is where i'm going to use a
larger dimensional latent space in order
to embed my data so i'm not using auto
encoders for dimension reduction
okay so um and now what i want to do is
just give you three ideas of you know
how may what might we be able to talk
about these types of problems without
going through the whole route of
actually going to um you know first
learning the whole underlying causal
graph and then through that trying to
predict the effect of one of these
interventions
and also maybe let me make the problem
also a little bit more difficult and you
know say what i also want to be able to
do is like use other kinds of modalities
where it's not even clear what the nodes
of my graph are right so before my
network it was like genes and i tried to
learn this gene regulatory network so if
you have expression data well that's
data on the nodes
but what about if i give you an image
like this from a cell right so it's
certainly not clear what the causal
variables are in fact you know the
pixels are definitely not causal
variables um so how can i even think
about causality when i have things like
single cell images
okay
so um that brings me kind of to the
first idea and um let me just discuss
this and it also in fact so where it
comes from is actually to solve this
kind of problem of like how do i use
even data from different kinds of data
modalities and how can i go between
different types of data modalities and
how might that help me actually get a
causality
okay so what are we what am i proposing
to do here so we have these very
different types of data modalities and
let me just concentrate on two of them
which is you know what we have seen
before if single cell images and single
cell rna-seq so expression data on the
other side
well we would like to be able to
translate between them and integrate
them right into one common
representation that captures you know as
much information as possible so a very
natural thing to do is to say like well
let me do an auto encoder that goes you
know from images to a latent space back
to images and an x and an auto encoder
that goes from expression data to the
latent space back to the expression data
and let me then just because you know in
my data set i just add random took out
some cells and and sequence them and i
took adrandom out some cells and image
them well it's the same population of
cells right so let me then enforce that
in the latent space it's the same
distribution i can do that by you know
adding a discriminator saying the latent
space so that i cannot distinguish cells
that were imaged from cells
that were sequenced okay just because
it's the same distribution of cells and
in this way i can translate between the
different data modalities
but even more what i want to propose
here is that different data modalities
might actually also allow you or or help
you get at what the causal variables
actually are
and so why is this the case and and here
i will you know and i will i'll defer
and also relate to of course other work
and causality where
where the the invariance principle has
been used but let me first explain what
i'm thinking of here
well so if you want to get at what are
the causal features well something a
feature is more likely to be causal
right it is if it is invariant to how
you're looking at it
so in this in this um joint latent space
here right where i have like my features
that are independent that are invariant
to whether i'm taking when i'm looking
at it from from an imaging land or
whether i'm looking at it from
sequencing land or from any other land
right then it should be something that
is more intrinsic to the cell itself and
hopefully more causal and hopefully the
more data modalities you actually have
the more different views you have on the
system the more you should be able to
actually get at um these causal features
so that's the the intuition or the
motivation here you know there is of
course a whole lot of theory to be done
here but that's at least the motivation
or the intuition for why these latent
spaces should help you to get a causal
features
now there is a lot of work on using
invariances with respect to
interventions for getting a causal
relationships
what i'm proposing here to do is to get
a causal features and let me also relate
to other work that is trying to do a
causal feature learning which is a
different type of approach without using
different types of
data of modalities but really using
either this entanglement in the latent
space or or using interventions to
figure out you know features that are
moving together and therefore should be
causal features so i think it is a
really exciting space here of somehow
combining different approaches to
thinking about
what causal representation learning
could be in terms of causal feature
learning and how maybe different data
modalities can help how having access to
interventional data could help and more
generally this principle of invariance
could help to either get a causal
relationship so so these these edges
between causal nodes or could even help
you to get at these causal features
themselves
okay so that's a high level idea of how
these different data modalities might
actually help you
um so if i go back here
and also ask myself so often this is
what is called causal representation
learning that the end goal would be to
actually identify the causal features so
i would say that causal represent where
i would propose that causal
representation learning should actually
be able to do more than just this it
shouldn't just be a representation where
you know your your your your features
are causal um or causal variables say
but it should also allow you to solve
problems like these causal problems that
i have down here of predicting the
effect of an unseen perturbation or
unseen intervention in the latent space
so the latent space should have that
information that i can you know apply
interventions and try to predict what
they will actually do
and you know how can we get there and
and how can we even think about um this
this uh question of predicting the
effect of unseen interventions
let me get to the second idea
and this is based on judea pearl's
causal hierarchy okay where i really
like this picture where you have at the
bottom you know your standard
association and standard things that
neural networks are good at finding
correlations you know um
for example you know how is my headache
well how is like taking an aspirin and
having a headache related to or
associated with each other you have the
second level here of interventions which
asks you know what will happen if i take
an aspirin and all the way at the top is
counterfactuals which is in fact what
all of causality theory today is
concentrated on and allows you to answer
really difficult questions of you know
what would have happened had i not taken
the aspirin
okay that's this counterfactual level
all the top here which is what cause
which is what causality is all all about
and um this is so in order to answer
these types of questions you really need
to know this full underlying causal
graph okay so causal structure discovery
and then you know estimating all these
these causal parameters allows you to
answer these types of questions here all
the way at the top
now what i want to propose is and you
know judea pearl would say this is at a
at the neanderthal level here but i'm
actually very happy with this
neanderthal level and i would like to
propose that you know in biology we
actually often care about this second
level and not so much about the
counterfactual level so unless you're
studying um say clinical trials but
otherwise all the questions that i
presented about predicting the effect of
an intervention they're all here right
there are questions like well what will
happen if i knock out genes one two and
three
or what will happen if i apply this new
molecule that i have not yet seen in my
data set all of the questions i talked
about are at the second level and in
biology you know you don't actually i
mean in this in the basic biological
questions you don't care so much about
or in science more generally about
counterfactuals right because i want to
do these predictions and then be able to
test these predictions anyways i'm going
to go to the lab and afterwards actually
validate whatever your predictions are
however these questions are not your
standard prediction problems like what
you have here in the association level
they are causal prediction questions
right because i'm not i'm actually i'm
trying to predict the effect of an
intervention
but they're not all the way up here
so it is to me
reasonable to believe that maybe you
know all of this like what we're doing
right now of like trying to learn these
all these causal graphs and getting at
these gene regulatory networks well
maybe
you actually don't need that in order to
answer these questions about predicting
the effect of an intervention
so there is i think
a really huge opportunity and there is a
need for define for you know coming up
with the right theory of understanding
what is really needed in order to to
answer causal prediction problems
that are not counterfactual questions
right which is what we have all of the
theory around right now so what is the
difference between these two levels and
how much less is needed in order to
answer these causal these causal
prediction questions here at the second
level and these are really the questions
that we need to do in drug discovery
right is or in all of these causal
transportability questions that i had
there where we have here all of the
different perturbations or interventions
here say my cancer cell lines and i want
to be able to fill in these these white
spaces here of what will this drug do in
this particular cancer context or i add
a new column here which is now covet 19
and i want to predict what will all
these drugs actually do in this
particular setting here where i have not
yet seen any of these of these
interventions
so that's um just a call for you know
that i think what we really want is some
theory here and that it is very
conceivable that we actually don't
really need to go all the way to
learning these causal graphs in order to
answer these types of questions
and um
let me end with like a third and idea
and you know and an idea of like how
could we go about this okay so um and as
i said i think in causal representation
learning i want to have representations
that can actually help me that cannot
just identify causal features but that
could answer these types of these types
of questions here at the second level of
having a representation where i can
actually predict what the effect of an
intervention is in a context where i
have not yet observed it
now if you put on your machine learning
hat i'm going to propose something that
is very you know
probably very natural um of like how you
would maybe go about answering these
types of questions
and um
you know so here is how i'm thinking
about it well we have our latent space
and you have say some drugs or some some
other interventions some intervention
that you have already observed in one
context okay so say here i have a
particular drug i have a particular
cancer type
and i know what this particular drug
does on this in this particular cancer
type
um so you know let me go to the latent
space i have here my cell type my
disease my cancer cell type i add the
drug and this is what comes out okay
now let me get data from covet 19 and
here is my you know my my my source
cough two infected lung epithelial cells
and i would like to predict what this
drug does on these source cuff to
infected long epithelial cells if i can
do that and i can rank my drugs right as
i explained at the beginning and rank
them based on and try to figure out
which drug signature is most
anticorrelated with the disease
signature
okay so how can i do something like this
well we all know these nice yosemite
pictures of yosemite in the summer and
transported to yosemite in the winter or
all these were too vac kinds of really
amazing you know
amazing applications of of generative
models and and here i'm doing it you
know not using gans but actually using
auto encoders but you know how these
things have shown to work quite well is
you just take the vector in the latent
space you take this vector corresponding
to adding a drug and you just move it to
your new cell type your new disease
context and predict that this is what is
you know here is the prediction but
you're moving it back into your
expression land and this is the
prediction of what you think this drug
will do
now you know this is such a simple idea
and it has been used in in in pharma it
has been tried in the pharmacological
industry um but and it has not worked as
well okay so um
so here and you can just test how well
it works because you have these kinds of
data sets so you can actually test how
well it works
and you know what i think we need and
here is just one you know starting idea
of how we can maybe go there and how we
have at least seen success in terms of
like just this causal transportability
problem of trying to predict the effect
of an unseen perturbation what we have
actually seen work very well um in
particular in the source cough ii
setting but you know this is just an
initial idea and of course there should
be a whole lot more research that's just
trying to to get this this type of
research started is to identify you know
what are inductive biases of of of
representation learning algorithms that
are well aligned with trying to answer
or trying to get at these causal
transportability questions
and you know i did mention these over
parameterized auto encoders for a reason
at the beginning
um because you know and it's very
intuitive to use something like an over
parameterized autoencoder because what
do you need in order for these kinds of
causal transportability problems to work
out well you need that the effect of a
particular drug in the latent space is
aligned right across different contexts
so that you can just move it around
and you know out comes the prediction of
of uh what this drug will do in the new
context
now if you have more space in the latent
space right instead of less space how
these ultra encoders are usually used
well then you have more space and and
you know it's much easier in order to
align the effect of drugs as compared to
if i'm going to a more smaller
dimensional latent space where
everything will be even more crumbled up
right even if your effect was linear
before now it will become more crumbled
up just because i'm going to a lower
dimensional latent space
but you know this is just one approach
where we have some theory about why this
is actually working out and when is it
working out but i think more generally i
think what we need in order to get to
something like causal representation
learning is to really understand and
develop the types of of representation
learning algorithms whose biases whose
inductive biases will be aligned with
the types of causal questions that we're
trying to answer in particular i feel
that these are causal questions that we
should be able to answer in the latent
space of what will happen you know can
you predict the effect of an unseen
intervention that maybe you have seen in
one context or can you predict the
effect of new combinations of
interventions hopefully it would be
something that you can add up the effect
of of single interventions or you know
maybe you want to find some other latent
spaces but those are the types of
questions that i think causal
representation learning should allow you
to answer
okay so these were three high-level
ideas um you know here is just to show
that this has
this has in fact worked for predicting
the effect of drugs in the source
costume setting and what is quite
interesting and we're excited about is
the drugs that actually came out just
entered some of so one of them in fact
the top drug just entered um phase two
clinical trials and you know we'll see
what actually happens with this one um
but let me end with this and just tell
you you know looking forward in terms of
what will come well if you're able to
predict and hopefully represent causal
representation learning will allow you
to do something like this to predict the
effect of unseen interventions well what
you can then do is answer amazing
questions and these are things that
we're very excited about of what would
be the id the optimal interventions in
order to move you from one state to
another and states can be move you
between different cell types so
reprogramming cells it can be moving you
from a disease state to a normal state
um etc etc it can be you know moving you
from an age state to a young state
so a lot of questions in biology that
are really fundamental questions are you
know cell state transitions and figuring
out what are the best interventions in
order to move you from one state to the
other and i think there is already a lot
of research in the space of you know
experimental design of interventions and
of course a whole lot more need for new
theory
in this setting where you can perform
interventions you can actively learn
from interventions and you want to
really identify the optimal
perturbations or the optimal
interventions in order to move from one
state to a particular outer state
and hopefully something like causal
representation learning will help you to
do that in this latent space where
you're actually trying to figure out how
to move around in order to get from one
state to the other and with that um let
me end hope i gave an intuition for what
i think causal representation learning
should be able to do how it connects to
different kinds of research that is
currently going on in causality and
highlighted some of the exciting
developments that have been going on
there what is being done um now in this
program and i'm ending with thanking of
course all of this work has been done by
amazing group of people um and my group
um and then of course um funding and
thank you all for
listening
thanks very much caroline
questions let me start well folks are
thinking about that um maybe you could
tell us a little more of the story
behind the uh drug that for covert that
is going into clinical trials two two
slides back
uh yeah perfect so
so what is happening and what is going
into clinical trials is so here these
drugs that were in this cancer screen of
course have a whole lot of drugs and
there's a more story but there is a
whole lot of drugs that are like that
are drugs against um in cancer field
that have a whole lot of targets
um so these drugs are not the ones that
are going into clinical trials what you
want to do right if you identify which
drugs are or your top candidates and
that's actually another use of causality
is to figure out if you have drugs that
have a whole lot of targets which one is
your putative causal target
and in particular that's what we did by
trying to identify based on these
targets that we found here for these
drugs which one is the one that is most
upstream of all of the differentially
expressed genes what comes out from that
analysis is that it is rip k1 which is
here
and what is currently in clinical trials
is is an inhibitor that is specific to
rip k1 so to this a putative target that
we identified based on these drugs that
is actually the most upstream of all of
these um all of these different uh
differentially expressed genes in fact
it also turns out that this this
particular protein directly binds to
source cough two proteins which is
another kind of exciting thing
fantastic thank you
any other questions
do we have any questions on zoom
actually
all right all right um please join oh
yes
so what do you mean by upstream uh
so i thought you avoided doing like um
sort of like a
whole network construction
uh and just learn an implicit
representation and that's how you
you achieved this but now when you're
talking about upstream did you really go
back to causal discovery
algorithms
we indeed went back to causal discovery
algorithms
um
and tried to identify which ones in fact
using exactly the kinds of tools that i
told you about at the beginning
we exactly use these types of tools
because now we do have a mix of
observational and interventional data
available we use these types of tools
for identifying based on all of these
genes that we have the differentially
expressed genes in in source cough to
infection plus all of these possible
targets to identify which one is you
know estimated to be upstream of all of
the differentially expressed ones and
that's how
independent of whether you're looking at
it in uh different kinds of cell lines
in fact it's uh in all of them it was
always um consistent that rip k1 was the
one that is most upstream
yes we did go back to you know it i
think at the end there needs to be some
combination of the two um but you can
get hypotheses like this i think you
still need to step often of actually
really understanding this causal the
underlying mechanisms right a
representation doesn't i mean it would
be great if the representation can give
that to you
but here we did estimate these graphs as
well
uh hi hi uh
thanks very much for the great talk um
so um
can you talk a little bit about the
representation learning aspect and its
relationship to causality like um
uh i think there was an implicit uh
implicit use of the fact that good
like um
you know um
[Music]
understanding causal mechanisms is
related to good uh representation
so uh could you talk a little bit about
what types of data you need to
have confidence in
that their presentation learn
will be causally predictive
yes
so i think if i can solve
so we have these data sets right we do
have these data sets where we have
different interventions in different
contexts
so if you can predict i think if you
have a representation where you can
predict the effect of an unseen
intervention
then for
basically
most problems that people are excited
about that's sufficient
so i would define and i'm just proposing
this i will
define that as a
a good enough causal representation for
many of the tasks in biology
and so that's how you would validate it
right by whatever you want to do you
find your representation but you can
solve these types of questions at this
level of trying of being able to predict
the effect of an unseen intervention so
i tell you you you tell me what happens
when you knock out gene one and three
you can use all of the other data
if you can do that
i think you have found a causal
representation
that is in the validation stage in the
like of your model
uh you would leave out some of this some
of the different perturbations so you're
talking about validation right now
correct correct yep
did i understand the question correctly
yeah so i guess um i mean but there's
also this thing that you mentioned that
that this over parameterization somehow
relates to
whether or not you will pick up a
representation that actually has uh this
ability
so um yeah
right so
yeah i think this is a great so that's
why i mean i'm saying like this is an
approach that we have tried so where you
know how we're doing this transport is
just by moving around vectors in the
latent space
that's one way of trying to predict the
effect of an unseen intervention
and there we have seen that these over
parameterized latent spaces actually
help you to do that to align the effect
of interventions that i have not yet
seen but i think it is an open problem
what i would like to see is you know
any representation learning algorithms
where you can define their inductive
biases in such a way so that you can
solve these types of questions
and i'm just giving one approach that we
have been looking into and trying but i
think there is a whole lot to be done
there
so another question i had is uh you
mentioned this in variance principle i
was actually wondering uh
how crucial is to use the all of the
techniques and the reasoning from from
causal inference
to be able to succeed in such out of
distribution tasks
instead of just arguing about invariants
and just having environments as our
principle and not even going into
you know like elements of questions i'm
not i'm not saying we should but i'm
just asking where is it most crucial to
use causal reasoning when doing causal
representation learning and not just
call it environment representation
learning
yeah so i to me where causality comes in
is where i'm trying to predict the
effect of an intervention
so
that is
right that i'm actually trying to answer
these types of questions and not so if
you're thinking about your standard
representation learning tasks of like
say captions and images and i want to
like you know find something that is say
invariant um i could also just be asking
about questions that are down here of
like predicting say i don't know whether
there is a cello inside my image right
your standard things
um but i do want to be able to answer
and this is to me where causality comes
in is when i'm having an intervention
this will only have an effect downstream
so i do need to understand something
about the causal relationships i don't
need to go all the way up here but there
is this is a really different level than
down here
and i think invariants can help you but
i think you need to also be thinking
about causality does that make sense
all right thanks very much caroline join
me and thank you carolyn for a really
fascinating talk
thank you all very much happy to
continue discussions online or
via email
thank you